So let me summarize, you've actually learned quite a bit.
You learned about probability of an event, such as the outcome of a coin flip.
You learned that the probability of the opposite event is 1 minus the probability of the event.
And you learned about the probability of a composite event,
which was in the form P * P …. P.
Technically speaking, this thing over here is called independence,
which means nothing else, but that the outcome of the second coin flip
didn't really depend on the outcome of the first coin flip.
In our next unit, we will talk about dependence
where there are bizarre dependencies between different outcomes.
But for the time being, you really managed to get a very basic understanding of probability.
So, let's take the next unit and let's jointly dive much deeper into the rabbit hole of probability.